remember the first time I ever came on
here cuz we were just talked about she's
never been on this show before I know
which is amazing I'm aware of that
brings a unique environment because it's
very you're very vulnerable really
because it's I don't know it just feels
I feel quite sure do you member the
first time in Liam Neeson was late and
we were on for like an hour and a half
we were out what was he doing he was
just like as he was coming from the
restaurant daughter
singsong one of the great we'll talk
about more but one of the things that
shocked me is that London looks fabulous
oh yeah it looks so good in this movie
and for you said is it nice to kind of
be filming in London because when you
thought of another before people taking
pictures and paparazzi but you don't
really have that so much no not at all
so it was great how did the shutters
come down on that I secretly filmed them
on what looked like a lighter but was
actually a camera for about two years it
was proper spy stuff and and yeah and
basically built up a case and then took
it to court and got an injunction so
that it's illegal for them to kind of
follow or sit outside the house I mean
if you're coming out with somewhere like
a premiere then you can expect it but
anywhere anywhere else
real quick so she told me this and I was
doing the Elephant Man and sometimes
paparazzi would follow us so I had my
buddy meet me at that they have it like
a camera at the side of the place where
I was staying and another friend in the
back of the car and the guy who I drive
with George his uncle who's a black cab
driver come we had this whole thing we
were gonna get them no one follows
you do get bother don't you yeah but not
that much you know it's not that bad I
mean it's more in the Europe or
something like if you go on vacation
times you get just murdered yet but it
wasn't unfortunate paparazzi yeah yeah
you have a sixth sense of when you're
getting captured yeah this was a couple
years ago but I do remember being
outside I lived in this little house in
Venice and there was no outdoor the
front door just opened right to the
street and I was putting my dog I think
in the back of the truck or something or
something I bent down like this and I
think you could hear the click you know
you just hear it you get used to that
clicking sound I thought oh yeah these
pants are really like they're oh I think
my ass no one heard us they did we
bought it there
that's one that's two nuts so are you in
a ways I'm glad that fountains over oh
yeah no because she honestly she was
about